[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur le plateau
de la grande interview avec comme invité
cette semaine
johanna le pape bonjour j'ai une chance
parce que vous êtes une rare d'abord
c'est une des stars de la gastronomie
française n'y a pas beaucoup de femmes
dans la gastronomie depuis notamment
dans la pâtisserie que c'est ça votre
votre couloir de nage comme on dit un
peu hein vous êtes connu un peu partout
dans le monde maintenant je me suis
aperçu de sa voix qui me soulage un peu
dans le cac 40
j'avais pas forcément l'habitude mais
j'irai vous avez acquis votre notoriété
quoi par votre talent bien sûr mais il
ya autre chose quand même il ya eu il ya
aussi une histoire il ya il ya un
discours parce que vous avez bouleversé
un peu les codes la de la pâtisserie
j'espère que je ne vous choque pas en
disant ça la pâtisserie pour tout le
monde sait c'est quand même du sucre en
gros et qu'on a l'habitude de servir à
la fin d'un repas comme récompense et
vous vous êtes arrivé si j'ai bien
compris en disant oui mais la pâtisserie
ça doit aussi respecter des aspects
n'utilisera nutritionnelle
alors on va regarder ça en détail pour
portable vous avez donc milité pour une
pâtisserie j'allais dire une pâtisserie
politique quoi engager
compatibles avec les contraintes du
bien-être
alors je sais pas comment vous l'avez
fait je sais pas pourquoi et c'est ça
qui nous intéresse comment ça démarre
l'aventuré johanna le pape se remet ça
démarre dans un restaurant et des flux
par ses parents ou pas mais pas du tout
a démarré depuis les terrains de basket
en fait puisque c'est là où j'ai
commencé le basket en bretonne
exactement le wes cates après du coup je
suis dans j'ai poursuivi mes études vers
une université sportif je voulais
devenir prof de ps et j'ai découvert
aussi parallèlement la boxe française
donc moi au démarrage store un
photographe
ça a été vraiment intérêt initiatique où
j'ai vraiment pu découvrir bain et m on
en a mais en vidant de compétitrice à
rude épreuve puisque je me suis jeté
beaucoup en compétition le basket c'est
unique et c'est un sport collectif il ya
une équipe exactement il faut gérer
l'équipe forgée à l'équipe la boxe c'est
un sport individuel exact mais c'était
complément pour oeil dent pour dent oui
bon c'est très intéressant dans le
cheminement parce que du coup on est un
sport collectif pour un sport individuel
c'est complémentaire et sa forge un
mental à toute épreuve qui nous permet
ensuite de continuer ce parcours en
pâtisserie qui était complètement oui
mais la solide si complètement insolite
aussi complètement étranger où ça voir
exactement en fait ce qui s'est passé
c'est que à mes 21 ans une fois que j'ai
ma licence je me dis bon très bien
est-ce que je continuais jeu devient
professionnel tout de suite ou est-ce
que je pars à l'étranger ben je décide
de partir en australie un nom et là je
découvre la pâtisserie française à
l'étranger beaucoup de succès exactement
et là quand je rentre chamboulement et
il ya plus de dix ans maintenant je
décide de complètement donc vous avez le
fait vos premiers
veaux première crème pâtissière vos
premières 1er 2e
en australie en australie alors en
australie j'ai commencé en une
pâtisserie et j'étais à la vente et dès
que j'avais un petit peu de temps au off
je partais en pâtisserie avec le
pâtissier rouler les croissants mais
donc c'était très très basique et quand
je suis rentré en france l'analyse est
un peu ce qui s'était passé et je me
suis dit partir avec un savoir-faire
français pour repartir en australie ou
ailleurs serait génial et donc c'est ce
qui a initié mon premier pas en
pâtisserie alors que j'ai vu que vous
aviez à ce moment-là recommencer à
travailler avec les plus grands chefs en
fait sans mal gré à gré ravel et des
trajectoires j'aime les locomotives un
gem excellence j'aime la compétition et
forcément quand je suis dans ce métier
j'ai découvert qu'on pouvait y avait
différents niveaux d'exigence
d'excellence et donc pour moi il est
inévitable d'arriver à paris alors avant
d'arriver à paris j'ai quand même une
formation à leurs aînés seraient donc
les l'école nationale supérieure de
pâtisserie qui est l'école d'alain
ducasse et d'yves thuriès je découvre
vraiment l'excellence de la patrie
française et je débarque à paris d'abord
au lutétia puis au meurice où cédric
brelet et maxime fait taxer cette
ducasse qui le premier vous a mis les
pieds à l'étrier indirectement à travers
son école et les chefs qu'il avait
employé dans son école à lui 1 sp parce
que on touche l'exigence est une des
meilleures écoles en france et là il ya
beaucoup dans d'étranges mêmes qui
viennent se former et 1 j'ai découvert
ça j'ai été complètement séduite par
l'exigence et l'excellence de la patrie
française j'arrive à paris donc en 2013
le lutetia le meurice exactement lutetia
meurice et qui me conduit donc vers chez
ladurée non ah oui vous êtes allé chez
ladurée vous attend encore après
en fait après le meurice j'ai la chance
de rentrer en équipe de france est de
participer à un concours qui le mondial
des arts sucré que je vais remporter
avec gaëtan donc en 2014 alors expliqué
moins ça j'ai découvert qu'il y avait un
championnat du monde des arts sucre et
oui en fait il ya deux coupes du monde
en france la première qui se passe à
lyon la deuxième qui se passe à paris
j'ai réalisé celle de paris les épreuves
sont un peu différentes et le titre est
un peu différent mais ça reste de coupe
du monde donc voilà je remporte en 2014
avec gaëtan second calorique j'imagine
que vous avez créé quelque chose pour
pour gagner ce championnat du monde
c'est un fait il sourit voilà qui
restera gravée dans l'île en fait on a
une thématique way et la thématique
c'était notre dame de paris et donc du
coup on a proposé un buffet artistique
c'est sans sucre et son chocolat c'est
sans pastillage avec en représentant de
nouveau le finalement mont notre dame
avec toutes les vidéos qu'on peut y
apercevoir et puis avait tout un panel
de pâtisserie qu'on proposait pendant
cette épreuve alors ce qui m'intéresse
dans votre parcours c'est que vous
n'avez pas non plus pris un chemin
traditionnel c'est allez vous n'êtes pas
allé dans un centre dans un grand hôtel
dans une grande équipe gastronomique
vous les avez fréquenté au moment de la
formation il fallait vous avez vous êtes
inspiré de tout ce qui est ce qu'ils ont
fait ils ont communiqué tout ça mais
vous vous avez pris un autre chemin pas
ouvert de restaurants vous n'avez pas
ouvert de pâtisseries non mais comment
on fait pour exercer son métier dans ce
cas va et oui en fait j'ai déjà à ce
moment-là repenser mon métier alors en
fait ce qui s'est passé après la coupe
du monde j'intègre quand même les
colonnes du casse pendant un an je suis
chef formatrice à l'école alain ducasse
paris 16e et j'ai des opportunités de me
mettre à mon compte et vous devenir
consultante en pâtisserie et ben qu'est
ce que c'est et bien consciente en
pâtisserie ça c'est beaucoup de choses
on peut y faire plein de choses moi je
faisais de la création et de
l'innovation à la fois pour les mâts k
gros alimentaires les startups les chefs
qui étaient installés mais également de
la formation des master classes c'est à
ce moment là que vous avez commencé à
forger
votre idée que la pâtisserie avait un
rôle culturel où elle pouvait avoir un
rôle nutritionnelle exact même été mise
souvent à l'écart en fait j'ai pris du
recul par rapport au monde et palaces
parce qu'il y avait une certaine
hiérarchie un peu enfermante pour
justement il est pas trop la pâtisserie
dans l'île dans les palaces alors la
pâtisserie 10ème l'hépatite la
pâtisserie mais si on veut dans la
brigade vous avez un petit peu
hiérarchique et moi je sentais que
j'avais beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
d'énergie beaucoup de créativité en moi
et qu'il allait être compliqué
d'attendre mon tour avant d'être chef
des années j'en redemande terrasse eu
pierre gagnaire c'est vrai qu'ils ont
leur petite idée de deux heures et puis
voilà il ya un règle rien il ya un temps
pour chaque chose c'est vrai que moi je
m'en rendais compte que je voulais aller
plus vite que le temps qui était à nous
donner en dans un palace pour grimper
monter les échelons donc j'ai décidé de
changer de cap et de ouvrir ma société
et de prendre aussi de la distance par
rapport
entre guillemets recettes
traditionnelles de la pâtisserie c'est
là que j'ai réalisé que j'ai re
questionner en fait la pâtisserie et je
me suis immergé chefs pâtissiers ont
nourris ont fait plaisir là par la
gourmandise par la beauté mais on
nourrit aussi donc pour moi le verbe
nourrir était pas assez bien respecté
j'avais envie vraiment donner plus de
sens dans ce dans cette direction d'où
cette pâtisserie scène est engagé alors
on va en parler un instant signale que
toutes les illustrations que nous avons
dans le futur sont vos vos créations
sont des créations qu'on peut retrouver
quelque part sur un site internet qu'on
peut dans distribution alors on pouvait
le retrouver l'année dernière et est en
fait aujourd'hui ce qu'on peut faire
c'est de retrouver en master classes
dans les écoles professionnelles ou
parfois encore aussi un courant lui à
l'atelier oui
votre votre idée j'ai bien compris très
ambitieuse et c'est un monde qui est un
homme bon un monde de mecs quoi mondobe
las plagas échanges sachant ça change ça
commence à changer quand on va voir dans
les cuisines des grands chefs ça
commence à changer en pâtisserie ça
c'est très féminisés ces dernières
années oui l aria deuxième problème
c'est que le la pâtisserie c'est le
dessert et que le dessert
c'est à la fin
c'était l'un des six géants qui sont
allés dans un trois étoiles ont été
complètement rasée acier par toutes les
saveurs qu'on aura fait passer c'est là
qu'il faut jouer la carte de la légèreté
qu'on fait la carte la légèreté est
absolument à maîtriser puisqu'on veut du
coup un dessert qu'ils soient gourmand
mais aussi très léger qui viennent
ponctuer un très bon dîner est donc
cette dimension c'est nous on va jouer
avec des sucs peut-être alternative on
va jouer avec finalement des recettes
très légère tout en gardant la
gourmandise peut être un bel atout pour
les fins dîner très copieux étoiles et
comment vous définissez la pâtisserie
bhl la batterie pour moi c'est c'est
beau c'est bon et ça doit être également
de st parce que l'idée est le pari que
je fais c'est d'amener la gourmandise
c'est se faire plaisir en se faisant du
bien ah oui voilà est-ce que ça une
culture la pâtisserie ça a une histoire
le rôle de la pâtisserie a eu a été
particulier dans l'histoire complètement
c'est c'est fédérateur la patrie c'est
toujours au coeur des meilleurs moments
de famille au coeur des milliards en
dehors vers des grottes des grands repas
du déjeuner et du dîner c'est ça sa
partie beaux moments de fête on veut
célébrer quelque chose on amène toujours
une pâtisserie pour rassembler pour
célébrer quelque chose donc c'est assez
c'est extraordinaire ça fait plaisir
c'est une gourmandise qu'on peut
s'offrir à différentes en mai alors
parce que c'est une gourmandise parce
que c'est une récompense
on pense très souvent notamment nos
grands-mères qu' on peut
dépasser les bordés et abuser un peu de
sucre ou des choses comme ça c'est ça
que vous voulez pas vous et ben en fait
mach dit on fait abuser des bonnes
choses si elles sont bien équilibrées de
bonnes choses je souhaite qu'elles sont
bien équilibrés en fait il n'y aura pas
d'impact négatif sur le moteur et c'est
tout le pari que je fais aujourd'hui
avec cette pâtisserie saine équilibrée
et engagé qui va sur ses produits de
façon intelligente je dis que vous
vous êtes un peu dans la mode la du
temps présent ça vous choque pas en fait
je comprends cette idée moi ça fait six
ans déjà que j'ai visualisé l'avenir de
la pâtisserie française dans cette
direction un des avenirs la patrie
française quel est ce un carnet à
travers des valeurs et cette pâtisserie
scène fait partie du futur donc sega six
ans déjà quelque chose que je prenais
aujourd'hui tous ali le coc vide aussi a
permis de se questionner sur notre façon
de s'alimenter et donc finalement la
démarche que j'ai eu que je défends
depuis six ans eh bien aujourd'hui c'est
une démarche que tout le monde aurait
envie de finalement de
d'emprunter ou en tout cas de découvrir
pour diversifier sa patte ive attendait
le coeur de la pâtisserie c'est du sucre
vous éliminez le sucre on élimine talent
si vous réduisez de sucre là puisque
c'est le sucre ok quel poison alors le
succès alors pour moi c'est pas un
présent le suc en fait c'est vraiment un
support qui avec la gronde il signe à
passer dessus qu'on va trouver sa place
mais par contre il faut jouer avec de
façon intelligente il peut être là en
support mais il va venir surtout
sublimer en fait les dac l'accord des
notes aromatiques on va jouer que la
poire le voit avec du jasmin de la
vanille il est vraiment là juste pour
sublimer les ingrédients dont on peut le
choisir on peut choisir sucre blanc
betteraves idéalement bio on peut être
sûr du sucre complet un peu sur du sirop
d'agavé on peut être sûr du de
différents types de notre sirop le cir
le sucre aussi de de coco qui est très
intéressant il y en a beaucoup et on va
aussi jouer avec les fibres parce que
l'intérêt est surtout c'est de baisser
l'indicé glycémique ça c'est tout le
propos pour avoir vraiment un impact
positif sur le corps et donc on va jouer
avec les fibres pourquoi pas tes légumes
donc il ya vraiment un double jeu c'est
à dire on ajoute des sucres à la juste
quantité et on ajoute des fibres pour
baisser passé après le dessert peut être
un véhicule pour l'eff libre exactement
bien sûr et on va apporter vraiment tous
les apports nutritionnels pour bien
digérer ce dessert ça fasse du bien ne
séduit la nôtre le corps donc à la fois
subliminaux papilles et notre corps
c'est tout le pari en tout cas que je
fais aujourd'hui bon on va revenir à la
dessus tout en détail sur le caractère
engagé de cette pâtisserie caractère bio
aussi un petit peu on est on est on est
on est véritablement là à une frontière
de 2-2 habitude de pratiquer notamment
dans les pays occidentaux dans les
autres à on se retrouve dans un instant
[Musique]
bien retour sur la plateau de la grande
interview toujours avec johanna le pape
qui supportent mais question de profaner
d'amateurs de pâtisserie de chocolat et
de sucre et qui elle s'est fait un nom
finalement dans le monde entier sur une
pâtisserie plus sobre plus engagée plus
saine plus nutritives fait j'allais dire
mais c'est à dire une pâtisserie plus
punitives peut-être d'autres juste alors
voilà la gourmandise avant tout
d'ailleurs à chaque fois que j'ai un
projet c'est la gourmandise il faut que
ça plaise à la première bouchée il faut
qu'il ya quelque chose qui se passe mais
en fait on ne se rend même pas compte
que cette pâtisserie et les gérances son
cas en soi qu elle est légère au bout
quand elle n'est pas très sucré qu'elle
est juste sur vraiment les arômes
faisait là par exemple on voit éclats
café chocolat cacao cru vanille et huile
d'argan on va vraiment découvrir ses
saveurs là on va même pas se dire que en
moins jeune pâtisserie c'est nous autres
choses puisque c'est que de la
gourmandise en amont le travail est fait
on à équilibrer les recettes avec des
ingrédients intéressant des farines
farine de riz complet farine de maïs
farine de châtaigne on va travailler
aussi avec un sirop d'agavé va
travailler avec l'huile d'argan première
pression à froid et c'est pour avoir une
batterie qui nous fait du bien mais la
première chose c'est la gourmandise
absolu et c'est la seule paris parce que
les gens quand ils en ont pâti three
scène ils se disent toujours oui voilà
qu'est ce qu'on va avoir dans cette
assiette donc l'idée c'est vraiment
d'aller de de séduire avec batterie
gourmande délicieuse et intuitif et la
nécessité de faire ce type de pâtisserie
est ce qu est ce qu elle correspond à
des résultats d'études scientifiques
précises selon lesquelles la pâtisserie
traditionnelle
serait un facteur d'obésité paris c'est
très simple en fait il ya juste
apprendre les recettes on les envoie
nutritionniste moi je les lunettes
socialiste qui m'accompagne toutes mes
recettes ont qualifié à la fois les kcal
mais pas que évidemment donc elle
qualifie les fibres on qualifie les
vitamines faut savoir que moi dans tous
mes procéder par exemple là on voit un
dessert à la rhubarbe avec 1,1 confiture
de framboises
on a une framboise fraîchement mixé avec
une halte l'alginate et bien à 100% des
vitamines voilà on texture à froid et on
garde toutes les vitamines donc ça c'est
intéressant et donc nutritionnellement
on peut faire le rapport et on attaque
serait très intéressante très équilibré
qui nous apportent des bienfaits dans
lors de la dégustation alors dans cet
engagement vous écoutant une impression
qui a plusieurs objectifs qui qui se
croisent mais qui sont pas forcément
contradictoires mais qui peuvent l'être
parfois l'aspect nutritif vous en avez
beaucoup parlé il ya l'aspect aussi
responsable des produits bio et
écologiques de proximité j'imagine que
vos framboises fraîches vous n'allez pas
d'où les servir en hiver exactement on
attend l'étude cette logique à veulent
exactement on va manger des produits de
saison
alors quid des aspects commerciaux parce
qu'il ya quand même une demande
aujourd'hui
quid aussi des traditions religieuses
qui interfèrent dans certaines cuisines
ou culturelles noël par exemple loi dès
sa bûche quand même un gros porteurs de
calories et ben justement moi j'avais là
j'avais donc une bûche qu'on va
peut-être voir tout à l'heure à l'écran
qui est sorti donc là elle était allée
noël dernier on était autour de citron
caviar citrons les citrons les
accueillerons caviar c'est complètement
la saison en acte et vous un portable à
part bordeaux et chocolat non mais cette
fois ci j'avais envie de proposer
quelque chose de tout à fait nouveau une
bûche jaune pur élevé risée au curcuma
quelque chose de très frais très léger
qui a beaucoup plu aux quelque 1 baba
imbibé ans dès qu'un sirop titre on on
avait donc un confit de concentré de
vanille et une mousse au thé noir pareil
sur séché un super pour le coup
torréfacteur à paris qui vend du thé
incroyable café vers l'est et donc là on
voit la bûche donc beaucoup de légèreté
le ba ba qui vient à l'intérieur a amené
beaucoup de comme un nuage et cette
crème très onctueuse très légère avec
notes de thé citron cas vert citron et
voilà une dégustation légère qui a
beaucoup plu et notamment ont parlé des
repas conséquent noël est un repas très
conséquent copieux à la fin on a
toujours envie d'avoir quelque chose de
léger souvent on va vers l'abus de la
voilà vite lasser mais donc si on veut
pas être juge de la scéne bûche
pâtissière c'était une proposition que
j'ai faite et qui a reçu du succès
annuel parmi les sujets qui fâchent là
le prix
coût cette pâtisserie cher est ce que
c'est une pâtisserie qu'on peut mettre à
la portée de tout le monde est-ce que
c'est compatible avec la nécessité de
répondre à une demande j'allais dire de
masse alors cette année moi je les ai
vendus pour être transparents pour une
scission personnes 69 euros j'ai trouvé
que c'était un prix très cohérent par
rapport à la qualité des matières
premières et je pense très abordable on
a envie de se faire plaisir à noël on
achète une jolie bûche très équilibré
avec un sourcing produits intérêt très
intéressant et bien 69 euros je trouve
que c'est un prix très cohérent et je
pense aussi je suis convaincu que c'est
une patrie abordable c'est incompatible
avec la grande distribution
moi je pense que oui parce
qu'aujourd'hui je travaille avec eux je
travaille avec l'ensemble de la filière
je ne veux pas me spécialiser que dans
l'univers du luxe moi je pouvoir toucher
tout le monde c'est pour ça que je
travaille aussi avec l'agroalimentaire
pour les aider à passer des caps et
finalement dans les recettes quand on
voit un petit peu les équilibres et a
plus beaucoup de choses qu'on peut
enlever pour m et faire la part belle à
des ingrédients enfin la pâtisserie et
les enfants c'est un problème est
merveilleux
tout démarre de la deûle aux ennuis
commencent là c'est ça c'est pour ça que
c'est que pour calmer un enfant va lui
donner un bonbon c'est pour ça que c'est
pour le récompenser ou si on le voit
l'atelier comment on fait se lier aux
rails à neuilly sur seine dans mon
atelier on les reçoit pour la cour
anniversaire par exemple il adore parce
que je réalise et madeleine est calculé
et c est donc tout l'intérêt c'est de
leur proposer des recettes équilibrées
ils se rendent pas compte ils s'amusent
et à la fin ils dégustent ce qu'ils ont
fait avec un taux de sucre équilibré
juste je pense que tout commence là à
dire que c'est dans l'éducation on
l'amène à l'air ça dégoûte déguster des
choses légèrement sucré très peu sucré
et les fans surtout découvrir des
saveurs le citron le basilic terrettaz
et bien ils ont développé un palette
très large et peut-être ne pas
s'habituer au sucre comme on a pu le
voir ces dernières années comment on va
faire avancer la formation d'éducation
déployant sa dans les écoles en
déployant pour les prix vous avez des
idées de chaoui des projets beaucoup
j'aimerais beaucoup pour anciennement
travailler avec l'éducation nationale on
pourrait travailler sur des programmes
de courts d'animation de chemin une
pâtisserie cette voie là avec un potager
il ya quelque chose comme ça imaginez je
vais prendre un exemple très simple
aussi c'est tom et josette alors la
série v sur une crèche une microcrèche
terre générationnel qui s'ancre dans les
ehpad donc les proches donc dans des
maisons de retraite et donc ses enfants
qui sont à la crèche vit avec du coup la
collaboration on va réaliser des
ateliers de pâtisserie où il y aura les
personnes âgées et les enfants de la
crèche on travaille ensemble on crée on
s'amuse avec des pâtisseries très simple
et très équilibré et tout démarre de là
j'ai vu dans l'émission en préparant des
missions qui est en regardant des
magasins il ya des box
offre comme cadeau à des enfants pour
qu'ils fabriquent eux mêmes leur part
c'est un fait en pâtisserie ça ça doit
vous en inspirer eh ben c'est très drôle
que vous en parler parce qu'on proposera
également à l'atelier et notamment avec
le digital puisque ça c'est la
pâtisserie c'est digitalisées en ce
moment donc un site internet sur lequel
on peut avoir tous les renseignements
que l'acteur ne sortent tout ça fait
atelier oreilles points comme la
pâtisserie et la crise qu'est ce qui
s'est passé pendant leur confinement
tout le monde s'est mis à pâtisser tout
le monde
les meilleures recherches on les voyait
c'était barca donc cette brioche
chocolatées il a eu des pépins et des
inventions pendant le pendant les
raffinements je crois qu'en tout cas les
gens ont re découvert leur cuisine ont
re découvert leur tablier way et des
ingrédients qu'il n'avait pas l'habitude
de travailler et se sont amusés et
notamment en famille parce qu'il fallait
occuper les enfants donc ça a été très
intéressant qu'est ce que vous avez fait
vous à moi j'ai pas dis c je me suis
aussi beaucoup questionné sur ce qui
allait se passer à la préco vide et j'ai
beaucoup partagé de choses sur les
réseaux sociaux justement pour inspirer
les personnes qui essayent donc à la
règle qui voulait avoir des recettes par
exemple votre parcours votre formation
vous emmener dans le monde entier à
commencer par l'australie mais vous êtes
allé un peu partout comment ça se passe
ailleurs la pâtisserie est universel le
rôle gastronomique et culturel de la
pâtisserie est le même dans le monde
entier avec le suisse riz les bases la
petite moisson française c'est français
pourquoi on voit tous ces étrangers
venir à paris par exemple viennent je
serai viable alors dans les écoles de
pâtisserie française on les voit tous et
il ya un public américain avec un du sud
asiatique etc on les voit tous venir à
paris pourquoi à paris ou dans les
grandes écoles françaises parce que tout
se passe ici que les bases de la
pâtisserie son française et ensuite ils
exportent ça dans leur propre pays et
ils développent pâtisserie alors après
avec leur petite touche personnelle et
culturels on a dit on va découvrir une
batterie moins sucré plus équilibré mais
on retrouve quand même toutes les bases
de la patrie la pâte à choux les tartes
ces choses que je n'avais pas dans leur
culture initialement comment vous voyez
l'avenir alors de la pâtisserie avec le
développement du fast food avec le
développement des recettes
amaigrissante qui est qui pullulent un
peu partout en fait la patrie va être
pluriel pour moi demain l'avenir la
pâtisserie ce sera plus une pâtisserie
classique qui ouvre un peu partout et on
retrouve les mêmes choix ce sera une
pâtisserie incarné par des valeurs je
m'explique je vais citer les belles en
vie d'alex borno où elle va développer
une pâtisserie sans sucre pour le
diabétique parce que son histoire à elle
c'est le diabète est là c'est ce diabète
maladie qui va déterminer la nouvelle
pâtisserie on a des gens qui sont
sensibles au gluten qui vont développer
une pâtisserie sans gluten d'autres qui
vont être vegan et qu'ils vont
développer aujourd'hui je pense que
c'est intéressant de voir qu'on a envie
de s'approprier la pâtisserie à travers
ses propres valeurs on va voir des gens
qui vont dire moi je ne prends rien qui
à plus 100 km de chez moi parce qu'ils
vont travailler très locale c'est ça qui
est intéressant c'est qu'on va déguster
une pâtisserie qui va être incarnée par
les valeurs du chef et non plus
peut-être des pâtisseries qu'on aura qu
on a toujours vu partout dans une
nouvelle et même proposition vous
rapprocher de l'individu et de l'intérêt
individuel c'est à dire que c'est à
pâtisserie elle est adaptée à son poids
sa taille à sa condition de vie à sa
façon de vivre a eu lieu où il veut
voilà elle peut avoir différentes
valeurs ça dépend où est ce qu'on met
son curseur moi mon curseur il est sur
le sein et l'engagement sourcing des
produits d'autres vont avoir différents
engagements mais je pense qu'une des
voies de la pâtisserie du futur c'est
une pâtisserie et inévitablement plus
elle et végétales on va aller je dois
donc pas qu'eux mais on va aller
beaucoup vers une pâtisserie végétal
parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est une demande
internationale une question que je
voulais vous poser vous qui êtes
originaire de bretagne oui notamment de
la bretagne maritime oui il ya une
pâtisserie inspiré de la mer
d'algues oui on utilise les honore
j'utilisais h soirée
vous utilisez le sort du tilly cela
exactement j'utilise des halles droite
comme un peu comme un vrai coup oui
évidemment je vais citer une marque que
j'ai découvert qui est super c'est une
jeune start up qui commence cégep tune
enap tu nous vends des paillettes en
fait de d'algues bretonne et du coup là
on va en utiliser pour faire des essais
justement pâtisserie et c'est
intéressant là on commence tout juste et
donc voilà la bretagne s'invite encore
en pâtisserie à travers la ligue ça veut
dire que la mondialisation dont on parle
n'a pas uniformiser les goûts en
pâtisserie est absolument pas non je
pense qu'aujourd'hui le chef va aller
vers alors c'est sûr qu'il ya en france
par exemple on a des attentes parce
qu'on a des souvenirs d'enfance qu'on a
envie de retrouver mais las à la place
de foot voilà nous on est en france en
asie ils vont avoir aussi un autre une
culture avec des saveurs on va plus à
l'est sur du thé matcha on va plus aller
sur des agrumes qu'est ce que c'est ça
qu'est ce que tu fais ça c'est un
étudiant tartelettes d'arte la noisette
sarrazin café
a pas mal
pour venir revenir à l'avenir est ce que
vous pensez comme certains aujourd'hui
c'était mieux avant pas c'était mieux
votre dans votre enfance qu'aujourd'hui
non moi j'adore vivre au temps présent
et construire l'avenir donc j'ai adoré
mon enfant j'adorais ce qui s'est passé
avant mais l'avenir on doit construire
différemment en prenant en compte notre
écosystème la planète et donc être avoir
une action vertueuse en ce sens est donc
aujourd'hui on questionne tout ça même
dans notre métier qui sommes au coeur du
système puisqu'on on achète des matières
premières dans quai et on auprès du
producteur il ya vraiment un impact
important aujourd'hui d'aller chercher
les meilleurs producteurs pour réaliser
une pâtisserie pour nourrir demain est
aujourd'hui demain alors les clients
pour terminer vous vous aviez fait ce
championnat du monde des arts sucré
c'était en
2014 en 2014 vous regrettez vous allez
remettre le vote qui votre titre en jeu
alors on se met pas être est ce que je
vais en fait ça vous le gardez ça va la
garder on a gagné on on laisse la place
aux autres bon alors ok questions très
pratiques johanna le pape si on veut on
veut avoir des renseignements
supplémentaires goûter la pâtisserie
comment fait-on alors on peut se
connecter sur johanna le pape point fr
semble s'être son atelier aura y aille
vers un point fr également et on peux me
connecter on peut donc réaliser des
cours en ligne ensemble ou à l'atelier
merci beaucoup je veux pas dire vous
nous avait mis l'eau à la bouche mais ça
c'est tout comme
merci beaucoup je rappelle que cette
émission on peut la retrouver en replay
sur la chaîne mais également sur tous
les réseaux sociaux via
le site internet de la chaîne arte
france pointé
[Musique]